Che cos'è questo strumento che sto
passando direttamente sui capelli
bagnati vi porto come a Londra a
scoprirlo arrivate in hotel Ho lavato i
capelli sono inutili capartista in
camera Una volta finito il make up è
arrivato il momento del Versailles ed è
qui che ho finalmente provato la ghd
2dside la prima other stayer 2 in 1
firmata ghd che asciuga mette in piega i
capelli in un solo gesto senza
danneggiarli Guardate quanto sono
luminosi A proposito di luminosità
questo è il suo primo vestito che ho
scelto di indossare per la serata
arrivata all'evento ho scattato alcune
foto su Red Carpet ho girato alcuni
video con le altre ragazze e poi ho
ritoccato la piega nelle postazioni che
avevano allestito il giorno dopo siamo
andati al ghd con tentab dove ci hanno
spiegato meglio la tecnologia del
prodotto qui per esempio Grazie allo
chalet8 trasformato la giacca di due
Style in una vera e propria piastra Io
vi giuro che non ho mai visto i capelli
così morbidi e luminosi ho scattato
alcune foto e per tutto il giorno non ho
fatto altro che toccarmi i capelli sono
davvero scioccata E Voi vorreste
provarla